>>> WE'RE BACK WITH OUR BREAKING
NEWS
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR
ZELENSKYY TALKED TO CNN TODA
FROM A BUNKER IN KYIV.
HE TALK ABOUT HIS COUNTRY'S
DETERMINATION TO FIGHT OFF THE
RUSSIAN INVADERS AND HE TALKED
ABOUT HIS MESSAGE TO AMERICANS
AND TO PRESIDENT BIDEN.
LET'S BRING BACK MATTHEW CHANCE
IN KYIV WHO CONDUCTED THIS.
TELL US ABOUT YOUR CONVERSATION
WITH PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY.
>> Reporter: YEAH.
FIRST OF ALL, WE WERE TAKEN TO A
SECRET LOCATION INSIDE CENTRAL
KYIV NEAR THE PRESIDENTIAL
COMPOUND.
WE WERE ESCORTED BY HEAVILY
ARMED MILITARY FORCES INTO AN
UNDERGROUND BUNKER WHEN
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY FINALLY
ARRIVED WEARING GREEN SORT OF
MILITARY FATIGUES.
I STARTED OFF BY ASKING HIM WHAT
HIS MESSAGE WAS FOR PRESIDENT
BIDEN AHEAD OF THE STATE OF THE
UNION ADDRESS LATER ON TONIGHT.
>> SO MANY MESSAGES.
I THINK THAT HE HAS TO GIVE
THOSE MESSAGES, WHAT WILL REALLY
WORK.
THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT.
TO BE VERY, YOU KNOW, USEFUL IN
THIS SITUATION, IN THIS WAR
AGAINST RUSSIA.
>> Translator: I THINK FIRST OF
ALL HE IS A WORLD LEADER.
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE
IN THE UNITED STATES TO
UNDERSTAND THAT DESPITE THE FACT
THAT THE WAR IS TAKING PLACE IN
UKRAINE, IT IS ESSENTIALLY FOR
VALUES IN LIFE.
FOR DEMOCRACY AND FREEDOM.
THIS WAR IS FOR ALL THE WORLD.
THAT MESSAGE SHOULD BE SENT FAR
AND WIDE FROM UKRAINE TO PEOPLE
THE IN THE UNITED STATES, SO
THEY UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS LIKE
FOR US HERE.
WHY AWARE FIGHTING AND WHY
SUPPORT FOR UKRAINE MATTERS.
>> FOR A LONG TIME, YOU
DOWNPLAYED THE U.S. INTELLIGENCE
ASSESSMENTS ABOUT BEING AN
IMMINENT RUSSIAN ATTACK.
DO YOU REGRET THAT?
DO YOU THINK IT LEFT THE PEOPLE
OF UKRAINE UNPREPARED?
>> Translator: YOU SEE HOW WE
WORK, HOW OUR ARMY WORKS AND
DEFENDS US IS A TESTAMENT THAT
WE'RE READY FOR ANYTHING, EVEN
THOUGH WE WERE PREPARING IN
ADVANCE, IT IS IMPORTANT NOT TO
LET YOUR ENEMY ANTICIPATE YOUR
REACTION.
THAT'S WHY I REALLY DID NOT LIKE
THAT SITUATION WHERE WE PUT
EVERYTHING AT RISK AND TELL THE
WORLD THAT WE'RE PREPARING FOR
WAR.
>> Reporter: THE UNITED STATES
HAS SAID THAT IT WILL NOT
ENFORCE A NO-FLY ZONE OVER THIS
COUNTRY AND IT WON'T PUT BOOTS
ON THE GROUND.
DO YOU THINK IT IS NOW TIME FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND OTHER
WESTERN COUNTRIES TO RECONSIDER
THAT?
AND TO HELP YOU, NOT JUST WITH
MILITARY HELP BUT WITH MANPOWER?
>> Translator: I'VE ALREADY
TURNED TO SOME FOREIGN LEADERS
WITH THIS REQUEST.
I BELIEVE THAT LEADERS MUST
SUPPORT DEMOCRATIC STATES OF THE
WORLD WHO ARE KEEN TO DEFEND.
THE POWERFUL ISSUE OF CLOSING
THE AIR SPACE HELPS US
TREMENDOUSLY.
THIS DOES NOT MEAN DRAGGING NATO
INTO THIS WAR.
WE SPOKE MANY TIMES WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND I'M THANKFUL
TO HIM FOR THESE OPPORTUNITIES
AND SUPPORT BUT THEY ALSO DID
NOT HEAR ME.
I'VE BEEN TELLING THEM THAT
UKRAINE WILL FIGHT HARDEST OF
ALL.
YOU WILL SEE.
BUT US ALONE AGAINST RUSSIA?
WE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO DO IT.
>> Reporter: YOUR ARMY HAS
ENJOYED SOME SIGNIFICANT
BATTLEFIELD VICTORIES.
I MYSELF HAVE SEEN SOME OF THE
RUSSIAN ARMORED COLUMNS THAT
HAVE BEEN TOTALLY HAMMERED AND
DESTROYED BY THE WEAPONS AND THE
MEN THAT YOU HAVE FIGHTING THE
RUSSIAN ADVANCE.
ARE YOU NOW CONCERNED, THOUGH,
THAT THE KREMLIN WILL DOUBLE
DOWN ON ITS MILITARY OPERATIONS?
AND HIT UKRAINE EVEN HARDER?
>> Translator: FIRSTLY, WHY WE
ARE WINNING OR WHY ARE WE
DEFENDING OURSELVES, BECAUSE
THIS IS OUR HOME.
YES.
RUSSIA WILL DOUBLE UP.
BUT TAKE A LOOK.
WHY OUR MEN ARE STRONGER, MORE
POWERFUL AND SUCCESSFUL.
BECAUSE AS I SAID, WE HAVE WHAT
WE NEED TO PROTECT.
AND THEY DO NOT EVEN UNDERSTAND
OUR STATE.
THEY DO NOT KNOW THESE STREETS.
THEY DO NOT KNOW OUR PEOPLE.
THEY DO NOT UNDERSTAND OUR
PHILOSOPHY, OUR ASPIRATIONS,
WHAT TYPE OF PEOPLE WE ARE.
THEY DON'T KNOW ANYTHING HERE.
THEY WERE JUST SENT HERE TO
FIGHT AND TO DIE.
>> Reporter: YOU SENT A
DELEGATION THE TALKS S. THERE
ANY HOPE AS THE WORLD WATCHES
FOR DIPLOMACY?
>> THEY DECIDED.
THEY DECIDED TO BEGIN TO SPEAK
ABOUT THE SITUATION.
AND I WANTED, I REALLY WANTED,
YOU HAVE FIRST OF ALL, EVERYBODY
HAS TO STOP FIGHTING AND TO GO
TO THAT POINT FROM WHERE IT WAS
BEGIN, YES, IT BEGAN, FIVE, SIX
DAYS AGO.
I THINK YOU CAN DO IT AND THAT
IS A VERY IMPORTANT MOMENT.
IF YOU'LL DO THIS, IT MEANS THAT
THEY ARE READY FOR THE PEACE.
IF THEY DON'T READY, IT MEANS
THAT YOU ARE JUST, YOU KNOW,
JUST HOW -- WASTING TIME.
>> Reporter: DO YOU THINK YOU'RE
WASTING YOUR TIME OR DO YOU
THINK YOU'RE READY?
>> WE'LL SEE.
>> Reporter: WELL, JAKE, WE'LL
SEE INDEED.
IT'S BEEN REPORTED FROM RUSSIA
THAT THERE ARE MORE TALKS
SCHEDULED FOR TOMORROW.
KOREAN UKRAINE AND RUSSIA.
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS I'VE SPOKEN
TO SAY THE BOMBING CAMPAIGN IS
SO INTENSE THAT EVERYTHING MIGHT
CHANGE.
>> IT'S TOUGH TO ENVISION ANY
KIND OF OFF-RAMP FOR PUTIN.
HE'S DECIDED TO GO IN AND INVADE
A COUNTRY AND KILL CIVILIANS
UNPROVOKED BECAUSE HE THINKS
THAT COUNTRY SHOULD BE PART OF
RUSSIA.
DOES PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SEE ANY
DIPLOMATIC OFF-RAMP AT ALL?
>> Reporter: AT THIS STAGE, NO.
HE PLAYED DOWN THE POSSIBILITY
THAT IT WOULD BE A DIPLOMATIC
OUTCOME.
NOT EVEN THE POSSIBILITY OF A
CEASE FIRE, EM, UNTIL HE SAW
THAT.
UNTIL HE STOPPED THE ACTUAL
FIGHTING.
SAW THE ACTUAL FIGHTING STOP
HIM.
AS YOU SAID, HE DIDN'T THINK THE
OTHER SIDE, THE RUSSIANS WERE
SERIOUS ABOUT THIS.
THE RUSSIANS MAY BE ENGAGING IN
THESE NEGOTIATIONS SO THEY CAN
RETHINK THE PLAN.
RETHINK THE TACTICS WHICH
CLEARLY AREN'T GOING VERY WELL.
AND PERHAPS GATHER MORE FORCES.
ON THE OTHER HAND, YOU KNOW,
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND THE RUSSIANS
HAVE BEEN BLOODIED.
THERE HAVE BEEN SIGNIFICANT
FORCES THAT HAVE BEEN DESTROYED
TO TAKE THIS COUNTRY AND TO TAKE
ITS POPULATION CENTERS.
I DON'T WANT TO RULE OUT.
WE SHOULD HOPE THERE IS STILL A
POSSIBILITY THAT THERE WILL BE
SOME KIND OF CLIMB DOWN.
THE TRUTH IS, WHEN IT COMES TO
THE PUTIN PUTIN, THERE ISN'T
MUCH ROOM FOR OPTIMISM.
>> AND PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY, I
DON'T MEAN THIS IN A CRITICAL
WAY.
HE WAS UNSHAVEN.
HE LOOKED EXHAUSTED.
DO YOU GET ANY SENSE OF HOW HE'S
HOLDING UP?
NOT JUST PHYSICALLY BUT
MENTALLY.
>> YEAH.
WELL, LOOK.
HE'S OBVIOUSLY UNDER A MASSIVE
AMOUNT OF PRESSURE.
THIS IS A HUNTED MAN.
HE BELIEVES HE'S HUNTED.
HE BELIEVES HE'S THE NUMBER ONE
TARGET OF THE RUSSIANS.
AND HIS FAMILY ARE THE NUMBER
TWO TARGET.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAYS.
AND HE'S MOVING FROM BUNKER TO
BUNKER.
THIS WAS JUST ONE OF THE
LOCATIONS WHERE HE SPENDS TIME.
YES.
HE WAS WEARING MILITARY
FATIGUES, HE WAS UNSHAVEN, HE
HAD RED EYES, HE SPOKE
EMOTIONALLY ABOUT HIS FAMILY.
HE WAS ASKED, WHEN WAS THE LAST
TIME YOU SAW YOUR FAMILY?
AND HE SAID I HAVEN'T SEEN THEM
SINCE BEFORE THIS WAR.
AND THEN EM, ACTUALLY, IT WAS
THREE DAYS AGO.
HE WASN'T HAPPY ABOUT THAT.
YOU KNOW, HE'S UNDER AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF PRESSURE.
HE'S BEEN THRUST INTO THIS ROLE.
WASN'T LONG AGO THAT HE WAS AN
ACTOR ON TELEVISION PLAYING THE
PRESIDENT IN A VERY POPULAR SORT
OF COMEDY ON UKRAINIAN
TELEVISION.
HE THEN ACTUALLY BECAME THE
PRESIDENT AND NOW HE IS THIS
FIGURE OF ALMOST LIKE, T